hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar early tick-borne disease
diagnosis with molecular testing knowing
what's at stake i am michelle action of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's events today's educational web
seminar is presented by the birds and
brought to you by DIA foreign molecular
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.lifebliss.org/events.asp
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
yet time for at the end of the
presentation
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit I now present today's
speaker Neil Anderson Neil is the
assistant medical director at the
barnes-jewish clinical microbiology
laboratory for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
Neil you may now begin your presentation
thank you everyone for joining me today
my name is MIA Anderson and today I'll
be talking about early tick-borne
disease diagnosis with molecular testing
and knowing what's at stake I'm going to
share a little bit of our journey
through tick-borne testing here in the
st. Louis Missouri area here are my
disclosures
here are the objectives for today's talk
so by the end of today's talk viewers
should be able to list the common
tick-borne diseases in the south-central
United States
identify the common clinical features of
ehrlichiosis caused by or Licio Shafi
Ensis and related species describe the
reasons for simultaneously testing for
multiple tick borne pathogens understand
the pros and cons of different
laboratory developed diagnostic
techniques for ehrlichiosis including
testing using the daya soren liaison
which I'll explain in detail later and
list the characteristics of an ideal
tick-borne disease diagnostic
so just a little background about where
we perform testing I am one of the
medical directors at barnes-jewish
molecular infectious disease laboratory
this laboratory serves a multiple
multiple hospitals and clinics in the
barn jewish-christian network and this
spreads out over the Saint Louis area
if this includes barnes-jewish hospital
which is a 1,300 bed academic adult
hospital st. Louis Children's Hospital
six community hospitals and multiple
community outpatient clinics so we're
seeing a wide variety of patients for
those of you who may not have been to
st. Louis recently or ever here's a
picture just reminding us of where st.
Louis is in the United States we're
known for having a pretty big arch
pretty decent baseball team some pretty
famous horses but we're also known for
our kicks we have a lot of tics in our
area and that's oh I'm going to talk a
little bit more about today now when we
talk about tick borne diseases I think
one of the first things that comes to
people's mind is Lyme disease so this is
an image from the CDC that looks at the
reported cases of Lyme disease during
2017 now what you'll notice is that Lyme
disease really is not a problem in our
area anyway in st. Louis we have very
very few cases and most most of these
are the results of travel to a mine Lyme
endemic area similarly other diseases
carried by xod scapularis are really not
common in st. Louis so these aren't the
disease's we're worried about what we're
worried about our diseases carried by
this tick the Lone Star tick or am Bluma
Americana and in fact st. Louis is
considered one of the epicenters of an
bleona Americana distribution that puts
us at risk for a very different variety
of tick borne diseases and I'm going to
expand on that a little later here but
first I want to talk a little bit about
the biology of an Blume Americana
so I'm showing you here is the life
cycle is the very typical life cycle of
a tick and this would apply to dermis
entering so DS scapularis different
ticks essentially what happens is eggs
are laid and they hatch into six-legged
larvae these larvae typically feast on a
small mammal they develop into nymphs
which which feed on a larger mammal
which develop into adults which feed on
the largest mammal in the lifecycle now
these mammals depending on the tick are
usually pretty well-defined
here are a here are some images of the
different life cycle stages of the am
bleona americana tick now what's unique
about am bleona americana is that
compared to other ticks it's quite
aggressive the host range is therefore
pretty nonspecific remember how I said
we proceeded the different ticks
proceeded through the different hosts in
a pretty regular fashion
however emblem Americana larvae can be
found on squirrels raccoons possums
turkeys even some large mammals such as
deer the adults and imps are also not
very picky regarding the type of animal
they feed on the adults and nymphs the
adults nymphs and larvae are also more
readily trapped from the field and
forest habitats compared to other ticks
so what you see in this image is someone
doing what we refer to as dragging for
ticks so you typically drag a white
sheet and the ticks are attracted to the
sheet and this is how we capture ticks
for studies now it just so happens that
emblem Americana
are more likely to be captured because
they more actively hunt out their hosts
they're likely over-represented in
sample studies so what you can take this
off as meaning is that an bleona
Americana is uniquely aggressive
so if we compare the major tick borne
diseases carried by EXO DS and and
glioma as I said before they are quite
different with EXO DS were worried
primarily about boo-boos iosys lyme
disease and a plasmosis and Powassan
virus and bloom on the other hand
carries ehrlichiosis tularemia dari
in alpha-gal allergy I'm going to expand
on these a little more
starting with tularemia so tularemia is
actually caused by Frances Ella to
lorenza's you can see the different
cases of tularemia that have been
reported through the CDC in the within
the United States during 2016 there is a
total of 36 cases in Missouri and this
is more than any other state you'll see
that this disease occurs even outside
the range of an bleona it's important to
know that Frances Ella is not just
transmitted by the emblematic but
there's other ways of getting this
however an bleona transmission is a
major mechanism at least in the Missouri
area patients with Franza sella they
they present with fever and a variety of
other symptoms and these symptoms give
Frances Ella its different names based
on how the patient is presenting so you
can have also all Cyril grit glandular
Frances Ella glandular ocular glandular
oral pharyngeal pneumonic or typhoid
--all here's an example of a ulcer
caused by Frances Ella so how do we make
a diagnosis of this disease
well it's readily grown in the
microbiology laboratory here is a
picture of a plate with Frances Ella on
it and if we can presumptively identify
it using basic bio chemicals
however this organism is highly
infectious to laboratory staff so it's
still very important that we know we
have a possibility of growing Frances
Ella
before we work with different plates in
the microbiology lab that's really all
I'm going to talk about for Frances Ella
I do want to mention starry though so
starry is southern tick associated rash
illness it's actually an acronym
it's an erythema migrans like rash at
the site of a tick bite so here are some
examples of stary rashes these patients
often have accompanying fever and the
cause for this has yet to be established
though it's secondary to the bite of the
emblematic
as far as diagnosis goes this is
diagnosed clinically you need proper
symptoms geography and history of tick
bites and this typically resolves
without treatment so the big challenge
with stary is to not confuse it with
erythema migrans which may be a result
from Lyme disease
and then finally I want to make sure we
talk just a little bit about alpha-gal
allergy mainly because this is a
fascinating new disease that we're
finding is caused by ticks that that
really we're just starting to learn
about these are allergic symptoms
triggered by exposure to red meat so it
may seem kind of strange that this is
associate with the bite of a tick but
what is actually occurring is the
patients are reacting to galactose alpha
1-3 galactose this is a protein found in
the cell wall of non-primate mammals and
patients become exposed to this protein
through the bite of a lone Star tick
it's been shown that this can actually
be caused by other ticks as well so we
do know the Lone Star tick is likely a
major cause of this disease this leads
to a hypersensitivity reaction and an
allergy to red meat the affected
patients develop wheezing hives and rash
following red meat exposure the true
incidence is unknown though most
prevalent though this disease is most
prevalent in the distribution of the
Lone Star tick and this is diagnosed
through traditional skin prick allergy
testing
talk about ehrlichiosis and that's what
we're going to focus on for the majority
of the day or licky osis is caused by
different species of the genus or Licio
and that includes ehrlichia Shafi Ensis
a wingy i or mirus oak Clarence's the
newly described Mira so Clarence's ver
Lakia Shafi Ensis is the most common of
these to be associated with human
disease
this is named these all are named after
Paul Ehrlich who is depicted here this
is a German microbiologist who among
many other things develop new staining
techniques and the cure for syphilis
though his claim to fame was ehrlichia
this is an obligate intracellular
bacteria related to the Rickettsia and
it's an intracellular bacteria within
monocytes so our Licio Shafi Ensis
preferentially infects monocytes the
other name for this is human monocytic
ehrlichiosis the other species of
ehrlichia are very important veterinary
pathogens
so here's a little information regarding
the epidemiology of ehrlichia first
cases of human monocytic or licky osis
were described all the way back in 1986
infection rates have steadily increased
since then as you can see here based on
this data from the CDC as you can see
when we were monitoring this using
passive surveillance techniques we had
an estimated point seven cases per
million population however with more
active surveillance techniques such as
mandatory reporting in some states we're
seeing about 100 to 200 cases per
100,000 population and the detection
rates continue to rise if you look at
the annual distribution of ehrlichia
based on this 2017 data you'll see that
four states account for approximately
greater than 50 percent of all cases
this includes Missouri Kansas Virginia
and New York so lakeya is a big problem
in these states peak incidence occurs
during June in July months and this
isn't surprising because that coincides
in the peak feeding of an bleona species
here is a look at the incidence of
ehrlichia infections here at our
Hospital barnes-jewish hospital as you
can see we have we have seasonal peeps
that occur primarily in June and July
month and these Peaks are very
well-defined and in fact during those
Peaks we can see approximately five
cases per week so it's most deficit we
definitely see a lot of cases during the
summer months
what are the symptoms of ehrlichia well
symptomatology typically takes one to
two weeks to develop following a tick
bite early symptoms are quite
nonspecific these include fever headache
malaise rash nausea and confusion and
for all intensive purposes look like a
flu-like illness however late illness is
more severe for Licio can cause man
injured encephalitis and organ failure
respiratory distress and patients can
even guy from ehrlichia infection they
may also have bleeding complications due
to thrombocytopenia which is also what a
typical part of the disease typically
though in most healthy adults disease is
overall quite mild
however the immunosuppressed an extreme
of age I tend to have these more severe
sequela
what are some of the outcomes of
ehrlichia infection exactly how severe
is in ehrlichia infection so this was
best detailed in a recent CDC review
from Heitmann and colleagues what they
did is they looked at all cases from
2008 to 2012 this was about 4,600 cases
that were reported in the US what they
found is that a lot of these patients
were quite sick approximately 57% of
those patients required hospitalization
about 14% for immunosuppressed and a
whopping 11% had life threatening
complications this included renal
failure meningitis AR D s di C pneumonia
and sepsis
and like I said her Licio Shafi Ensis
can kill patients the overall case
fatality rate in this report was about
1% which is actually quite high it's
much higher in extremes of age as you
can see here the it most certainly is
quite high in patients that are above 70
years of age however we have a very high
peak in patients less than 5 years of
age and this is a fatality rate of
nearly 4% so that is quite high
considering all the other diseases that
might manifest in children of that age
the authors hypothesized why this might
be so highs a lot of office a lot of
people think actually that physicians
may be unwilling to treat children and
Pyrrhic ly with doxycycline given the
side effects of teeth-staining if they
aren't sure that the offending organism
is ehrlichia so this kind of points
towards the need for a rapid and
accurate diagnostic test
I just want to touch briefly on some of
the other species of ehrlichia and
they're important so starting with
ehrlichia or winged knee I this was
recognized in 1999 as another causative
agent of human ehrlichiosis prior to its
discovery it was thought to be
exclusively a canine pathogen it has the
same vector as ehrlichia Shafi Ensis and
glioma americana and it however it
infects granulocytes rather than
monocytes like ehrlichia Sapienza human
infections are also more rare than
ehrlichia chef dances in fact there's
only been 55 cases that were reported in
that 2008 to 2012 CDC report and those
are mostly in immunocompromised patients
and those patients had milder disease
there were no reported deaths second
area or Licio wing yet
so if we look at the comparison between
the between ehrlichia Shafi ANSYS and
our Licio ingly away me i incidents what
we find is that the incidence of
ehrlichia Shafi ANSYS is far more higher
however the incidence of ehrlichia wing
GI is certainly on the rise
so as of 2017 we have a hundred and
eighty-five cases and you can see a
steady incline in cases from 2008 to
2012 and many believe this incidence is
significantly underestimated given the
relatively milder disease so we're
probably not testing for a wing II I is
often but also many believe that a lot
of cases of ehrlichia or wing GI are
mistakenly reported as over lakiya Shafi
Ensis so much more needs to be learned
about ehrlichia wing GI there are other
species that can cause ehrlichiosis one
that I mentioned was ehrlichia myris
Okhla rancis this is a newly described
species there have been isolated cases
in Wisconsin and Minnesota the vector
for this is different it's xod
scapularis and since its discovery in
2009 115 cases have been described this
two causes a very mild disease with no
reported deaths and its presence may
explain some of these isolated cases of
ehrlichiosis that are outside of the am
bleona americana range so these might
actually have been her licky Amira's Oh
Clarence
but now getting to the diagnosis of
ehrlichiosis so this really should be
suspected by physicians when they have
this trip this typical triad of basic
laboratory findings patients with
ehrlichia offices have rhombus i2p mia
leukopenia and elevated liver enzymes
the organism itself can be directly
visualized on a blood smear so what
you're seeing here this cell with the
dark blue cytoplasm is a mono site and
you can see the large purple nucleus of
the monocytes and next to it a smaller
purple more you'll which is a collection
of the ehrlichia Shafi ANSYS organism
this is typically hard to find though in
a peripheral smear since monocytes are
only a small proportion of the
circulating white blood cells techniques
can be used such as puffy coat
examination to to be able to have better
sensitivity when actually looking for
the organism so the way this works is
you splints pin a blood tube you pull
off the buffy coat which is enriched for
white blood cells and then you have a
greater likelihood of finding the
organism however this is not routinely
done the best diagnostic test for
ehrlichiosis is our molecular techniques
there's unfortunately fda-approved pcr
assays are not currently available most
of these assays that are in use are real
time PCR lab developed many have or
several have been described though
there's only a handful of these actually
available for routine clinical testing
as such testing is typically sent to
state or commercial reference
laboratories this can be problematic
since disease can be fatal and less
treated properly promptly so how do we
diagnose ehrlichiosis here at our
hospital previously we were performing
testing using an in-house laboratory
assay performed on the light cycler 2.0
however in February 2018 we had to
discontinue this testing this was for a
couple of reasons one was we were
transitioning lab space so we were
moving from our st. Louis Children's
Hospital virology lab into our molecular
infectious disease laboratory which meat
meant we had to reevaluate our entire
test menu at that time the manufacturer
made the decision to no longer support
the light cycler 2.0 so a choice was
made to switch platforms therefore we
made the decision to send testing to a
reference laboratory while examining new
options
this is just a little bit about the
overall pcr capabilities at our
laboratory the majority of our testing
is laboratory developed and it's
perfectly of our biology testing is
laboratory developed and is performed
using the dice Oran liaison test the way
this works is you have a patient
specimen it is extracted on an automated
extractor the extracting reagents are
loaded on to this universal disc and the
disc is loaded onto the integrated
cycler for real-time PCR
the real-time PCR for some of these
assays anyway is performed using TaqMan
probes which are seen here in the
instrument allows for simultaneously
thermo cycling and measurement of
fluorescence so dye Sauron has multiple
ASRs that are available and we use a
fair amount of them we're doing testing
for CMV HSV ad no para cove iris hhv-6
bzv parvo and Bordetella pertussis now
since we're using this instrument for so
many different applications it was very
attractive in when we saw in July 2018
daya Soaring released ASR to the
detection of ehrlichia so we decide to
evaluate these ASRs now one of our early
questions was is or Licio detection
enough it is by far the most common and
concerning pathogen in Missouri and
that's based on the data I've already
shown you however st. Louis is only a
few hours from what we refer to as
exodia country and in fact one could
argue that we all are already in exodus'
country this coupled with the fact that
many patients don't even remember a tick
bite and essentially no one actually
brings in a tick for ID means we need to
plan in our laboratory for both an
bleona and EXO DS exposure so based on
that you can kind of go back to the
different diseases caused by these
different ticks and consider what we
should include in an ideal assay so Lyme
disease is going to be diagnosed sir
logically so we're not worried about
that in the molecular assay tularemia is
readily cultured dari is diagnosed
clinically alpha-gal allergy is
diagnosed through allergy testing
Powassan virus is interesting it does
need PCR for detection but at this time
the distribution and overall
significance is unknown and we don't
typically see a lot of this in our area
but BZ osis is interesting as well so
PCR definitely helps with the diagnosis
of BZ osis however most cases in Babesia
will present
and be visible in the CBC since this is
an intracellular parasite of
erythrocytes so at least for our
hospital we feel confident that we catch
a case of aviso --ss on a CBC however as
I described or licky osis you're not
going to catch on the CBC so you need
pcr and the same goes for anaplasmosis
anaplasmosis is best diagnosed using PCR
I'll explain why anaplasmosis is the
causes or excuse me anaplasma
phagocytose column is the causative
agent of anaplasmosis this formerly was
considered in ehrlichia and was formerly
called human granular acidic
ehrlichiosis it's a close relative of
ehrlichia the disease spectrum is also
very similar to leaky OSIS patients
often have nonspecific fever headache
and malaise and can have severe disease
particularly if they're a part of an
at-risk population patients also develop
the typical lab findings of leukopenia
rhombic edenia and elevated liver
function enzymes the diagnosis of
anaplasmosis can be made on the
peripheral blood smear you you can see
more you'll a similar to what we saw for
ehrlichia within granulocytes though in
order to do this with adequate
sensitivity you need to examine eight
buffett buffy coat
therefore diagnosis is best accomplished
using PCR so based on that we this is
what we so we knew that we wanted a
assay to diagnose both or Licio and
anaplasma currently Dyess or molecular
has primers available to cover three
tick borne diseases this includes
ehrlichia anaplasma and Babesia so this
allows for tailing of testing according
to our local epidemiology I kind of
walked you through our rationale but we
decided to multiplex for both or Licio
and anaplasma so I'll walk you through
our assay design and evaluation on the
way we designed our assay is we plan to
have whole
blood specimens extracted on the kaijin
easy one these would be tested using
multiplex primer probe sets for
ehrlichia and anaplasma and run on the
liaison MDX way we evaluated this is we
used a Bank of frozen whole blood
samples submitted for Licio and
anaplasma testing from over the past ten
years we were quite lucky to have this
Bank on hand we tested a total of 123
previously tested specimens this
included
76 positive specimens positive for a
range of different ehrlichia Shafi ANSYS
a wing GI and canis and 22 and a plasma
phagocyte hofland positive specimens
this also included 47 specimens
submitted for routine testing was found
to be negative for Licio and anaplasma
so this is these are example results
from the assay on the left you have an
ANA plasma positive so what you're
seeing is a green amp curve that
correlates to the anaplasma positivity
and a purple internal control curve the
ehrlichia ad set or on the right is a
ehrlichia positive specimen so we have
the red ampere correlating to ehrlichia
and we have our internal control
acid did we compare to so these were all
previously tested using the Roche light
cycler 2.0 that and a previously
published laboratory developed asset the
publication is at the bottom of the
slide here if anyone cares to read more
about this acid it is frequently used by
several different reference laboratories
on this real-time PCR assay utilizes a
single pair of fret probes it's capable
of detecting and differentiating through
melt curve analysis and a plasma or
lakeya Shafi Ensis for Licio wingy i and
ehrlichia o'clair inches so
how did our assay stack up to the
comparator what you're seeing here is
our accuracy data for ehrlichia as you
can see we had a fairly high positive
percent agreement negative percent
agreement and overall percent agreement
all greater than 90 percent will I'll
point out is that we had one extra case
detected from a patient with tick
exposure and ehrlichia like symptoms so
this may be a new detection with this
new acid will also point out are these
five potential false negatives so there
were five specimens that were positive
on the initial comparator asset but
negative on our new a say this was five
out of fifty four so if we break that
down and look at the different species
what we found is that it was actually
the it was actually four out of the 25
or Licio wingy i that we failed to pick
up with the new asset however two of the
previous auricular Licio a-wing GI
positives that were negative on the new
assay actually did have crossing points
greater than 40 CT so what we did based
on this is we looked at our cut-offs and
we examined this using 45 as a cut-off
for positivity when we use 45 as a
cut-off for positivity what we found is
that we only had one out of twenty case
27 cases of Shafi ances that were missed
and two out of 25 cases of a-wing me i
that are missed and no cases of canis
now you may argue you don't want to miss
any cases however i'll point out that
some of these specimens were greater
than five to ten years old so a lot of
these specimens potentially degraded
over time and unfortunately we were
unable to test using the comparator
method in real time to see if they still
would have been detected by the
comparator method so overall I think
this data looks pretty good if you look
at our anaplasma Saiga site top form
accuracy that data looks pretty good as
well we had a very high positive
negative and overall percent agreements
all higher than 95
set
another thing that we did is we looked
at precision and limit of detection for
both or licky and anaplasma now I
understand this is a very busy chart but
what we did is on the on the left hand
column here what you can see is we
prepare different concentrations and we
ran them in duplicate on three different
days and that's what you see on the top
the different days of testing and so all
in all each concentration got ran six
times we defined the limit of detection
as the last concentration at which we
got six out of six detection so if you
look at this data we were able to detect
ehrlichia six out of six all the way
down to a concentration of 500 copies
per milk
so our estimated limited affection was
500 copies per milk
similarily for anaplasma we did the same
thing and we were able to detect for
anaplasma all the way down to 250 copies
per mill
so what do these limits of detection
actually mean well if you compare these
limits of detection to the limit of
detection that's been published for our
comparator acid they're actually much
lower at least tenfold lower so we know
that this assay is adequately sensitive
for patient testing at least it has the
analytical sensitivity needed for
patient testing another thing we looked
at was inhibition of the assay by
different things commonly encountered in
patient specimens specifically we looked
at laity Mia and bilirubin and what
you'll see here is given increase in
concentrations of laity Mia and
bilirubin we still maintained a
qualitatively positive result however we
did see some drift in the CT reported by
the assay so there is some inhibition
observed with light emic and etic
samples so it's certainly not enough to
preclude clinical testing so just to
summarize our validation data the
laboratory developed a say that we had
put together was deemed to have
acceptable accuracy for detection of
both or Licio and anaplasma the limit of
detection rivals that of currently in
use laboratory developed tests for
growth or Licio Nana plasma and neither
assay is significantly affected by
physiological levels of light emia or
icterus so that being said because we
did see some drift in the CTS we report
results with a disclaimer that false
negatives may be seen with highly light
emic or exericse samples just to be safe
so based on this our validation was
completed and we were able to put in
place routine testing which we initiated
in November 2018 now is this a success
now you know I will say putting in
ehrlichia assay into play in the month
of November is not exactly something
you're going to get kudos for you know
it summer's over and so we're not seeing
a lot or Licio and it's not really the
best time or at least the most useful
time to go live with an assay so we were
feeling a little down on
so until we had this case on Christmas
Day so I want to walk you through this
case and kind of tell you this story and
I think it really highlights why this
assay is important this was a 17 year
old male admitted with fever and altered
mental status
this guy was found to be hypotensive on
arrival to the hospital of concerns for
sepsis so he was quite sick two weeks
prior the patient had developed a rash
on his right forum he was initially
treated with bactrim with only mild
improvement however around day ten of
treatment he developed fever nausea and
vomiting these symptoms worsened for
four days prior to presentation when he
arrived he was very sick he was
initially stabilized with fluid and
pressors and started on broad-spectrum
antibiotics numerous tests were sent to
diagnose a at this time just simply
suspected infectious etiology blood
cultures were negative
EB D serology was negative CMV serology
respite respiratory multiplex hepatitis
serology and HIV serology all negative
however he did have some concerning
laboratory findings those white count
was quite low hemoglobin and hematocrit
were okay platelets were also very low
so he's leukopenia and thrombocytopenic
on abdominal imaging he had splenomegaly
and interestingly he had a very high
ferritin his ferritin was a was above
5700 and this is very high when you
consider the normal ferritin is around
400 so based on these laboratory
findings and clinical presentation the
physician suspected a specific diagnosis
now it's not the diagnosis you're
thinking it's not what we've been
talking about and keep in mind this is
winter so at this point or Licio really
wasn't on their radar at this point the
dye the diagnosis that was being
suspected is what I have depicted here
is of in the bone marrow of a unrelated
patient so this is what our patient
might have looked this is what the bone
marrow from our patient might have
looked like how to biopsy been performed
what you're seeing here is
something quite bizarre there's white
blood cells that are phagocytosis red
blood cell precursors and other white
blood cells so this is highly highly
abnormal and these are findings
consistent with what we call
hemophagocytic so what was suspected
that this patient had is something
called hemophagocytic
lymphohistiocytosis or as we call it HL
h this is a rare but potentially fatal
syndrome caused by an uncontrolled and
ineffective activation of monocytes
leading to hyper inflammatory State it
can be primary or secondary so the
primary causes for this are usually some
sort of defect in a natural killer cell
protein but it can secondarily be
triggered by a viral or bacterial
infection
for diagnosis of this illness there's a
there's a set of criteria that must be
met and you must meet five of these
eight criteria so some of these criteria
are easy to measure such as fever fever
splenomegaly or by side uppy Nia some
are more hard because they require
specific testing such as elevated
soluble il-2 receptor or NK cell
function testing and some of these
require invasive techniques such as
demonstrating chemo phagocytes houses on
a bone marrow biopsy so without having
these esoteric or invasive tested tests
perform our patient met some of the
criteria already so our patient had
fever when a megali dive site of Pina
and elevated serum ferritin so he was
very close to achieving the five out of
eight criteria for this diagnosis
so treatments of secondary so there's a
chance our patient at secondary hlh
treatment of secondary HLH is entirely
dependent on treating the underlying
cause the most common causes of HLH that
have been documented literature our EBV
and HIV however we recently had
performed investigators from our
institution had performed a review of
all hlh cases reported from october 2003
to 2014 at our hospital
this included 76 cases reported over a
10-year period and surprisingly enough
we found that ehrlichia Shafi Ensis was
found to be the causative agent in five
out of 76 of these cases those seven
percent of our cases of hlh two of these
patients had very severe disease with
CNS involvement here's a breakdown of
the different patients that had
ehrlichiosis and HLH well I'll point out
is that they all had very very high
ferritin results based on this we did in
addition excuse me an additional
look-back was performed and what was
found is that there were four additional
patients that were identified during
that time period that also had very high
ferritin results and ehrlichia infection
they likely fit the hlh criteria they
only had four fulfilled at that point
but the additional more invasive testing
was incomplete so what's the bottom line
here well what we found in this study
was that hlh is much more common in our
area than we thought overall we had 76
cases over ten years and if you put that
in context that's more than one case
every two months this and that's pretty
significant when you think of the fact
that this is a very life threatening
illness ver Licio is a relatively common
cause of hlh at least in our location
and if we were to account for those
patients who were completely tested for
hlh approximately 12% of our hlh cases
are secondary
to ehrlichia so based on that we have
set up some Hospital best practice
measures what we've told our physician
is physicians if they suspect hlh they
should always simultaneously order or
Licio testing so now let's go back to
our patient our patient had would look
like hlh however it was Christmas time
the physician was very doubtful that
this patient had ehrlichia however
ehrlichia testing was still ordered and
in fact what we found is that the
patient was positive this is the PCR
readout from this patient and we found
that the patient was positive with a
cycle threshold of 23 these results were
communicated with the physician and
given that the result was unexpected for
Licio over Christmas time is most
certainly unexpected the test results
were repeated and once again they were
found to be positive so how did this
resolve this patient was diagnosed with
ehrlichiosis secondary to HLH the rapid
diagnosis allowed us to start doctors
allowed for the physicians to start
doxycycline immediately the patient
markedly improved when doxycycline was
started this patient made a complete
recovery and all laboratory findings
normalized il-2 receptor testing was
indeed found to eventually be elevated
and so eventually this patient was
diagnosed with HL h also unferth
questioning the patient revealed that he
cleared brush for a job and was an avid
hunter I'll also make a point to mention
that here in st. Louis anyway we had a
very mild December so it's entirely
possible that we did have ticks out
during that time
so I think so the reason why I bring up
this case is I think it really
highlights some of the benefits of
performing testing in-house this rapid
turnaround time allows the physician to
act promptly on a very unexpected result
performing the tests in-house also gave
us the ability to troubleshoot the
unexpected result and convince ourselves
that was true we actually were able to
perform repeat testing there on-site and
have it done very quickly also offering
the test in-house me I would like to
think made it a lot more likely that the
physician was willing to order it
knowing that they were going to get a
rapid turnaround time and it wasn't
something that they were going to have
to follow up on a week later
based on this I'd make the general
recommendation that laboratory should
considering often offering in-house
testing for important tick pathogens
particularly the tick pathogens that are
important in their area
so that brings up the question who
should offer what so if you look at the
distribution of the different tick borne
diseases you'll notice that there's some
very clear epidemiologic differences and
this is going to necessitate very
different approaches based on the
geography so basically you know one test
that I may go live with the New England
area may not be the right test for the
st. Louis Missouri area also an
important consideration are additional
targets to include in these tests in the
future so one of these is Heartland
virus the Heartland virus is a novel
virus found to be carried by the Lone
Star tick as of 2018 there's been a
total of 40 cases of Heartland virus
reported within the central to southern
United States
it's not currently notifiable or tested
for routinely though so this could be a
very large underestimation of the actual
of the actual incidence of this virus
there are similar laboratory and
clinical findings to or Licio so once
again a lot of cases of ehrlichia made
if they're being just diagnosed
clinically they may actually be cases of
Heartland viruses to date all cases have
been hospitalized so at least in the
cases that have been identified they've
all been in severely ill patients and
there have been deaths reported
another target to consider is Bourbon
virus this is a bourbon there this is a
virus that was first isolated from a
patient that expired in Bourbon County
this is a County on the border between
Missouri and Kansas this patient was
actually being tested for Heartland
virus however during plaque reduction
assays an unexpected virus grew that
most definitely was not Heartland virus
this was identified as Bourbon virus
recently Bourbon virus has been shown to
be present in a small proportion of
ambling Alma ticks less than 1% though
it most certainly is out there it's far
more rare than Heartland virus though
additional cases and fatalities have
been described and it has symptoms and
laboratory findings similar to ehrlichia
so one question you may ask is do we
need to routinely test for these viruses
they're quite bad but they're quite rare
and also we don't have defined treatment
for these viruses you know one thing we
might have to ask though is are we sure
they're rare we need to keep in mind
testing bias these viruses are only
tested for in the most dire of
situations this will make them appear to
be both more rare and more severe than
they actually are
so we may not have the entire picture
regarding these viruses however I think
we can learn the lesson from Powassan
virus so Powassan virus is a tick-borne
Flavie virus this is carried by saudis
scapularis this is a rare virus but it
can cause a severe neurologic disease in
humans it was first characterized in
1970 and it wasn't until 2001 that it
became a notifiable disease prior to
2006 only 20 cases were reported in
literature these were patients that did
have severe disease however when we
started looking for it we started to
find this virus enhance surveillance
started in Wisconsin 2003 and enhanced
surveillance started in Minnesota in
2006 and since then we found many cases
in those areas
you
what what's market about palace and
virus is after the enhanced surveillance
not only do we find an increase in cases
a lot of these cases were very severe so
only 10% of cases were non neuro
invasive as 90% had some sort of
neurologic sequela so based on the
increase in opossum testing we learned a
lot about the virus we learned its more
common than originally thought and we
also learned that it's an important
cause of very severe disease so with
that in mind we may need to start
thinking about testing for these viruses
on a more regular basis one thing that's
for sure though is that this most
definitely is going to become something
that we are going to have to address
soon the habitats of ticks are expand is
expanding what I'm showing you here is
the habitat of xod scapularis and
highlighted in red are areas where the
tick had not been previously reported
but we know the tick to be now I can
show you a similar diagram for an
applause or excuse me for a moment as
well so this is something that we are
going to have to deal with more as the
range for these ticks expands but
looking towards the future we need to be
able to simultaneously detect similar
pathogens
there's too much overlap in
symptomatology for tick borne diseases
and really asking the physician to tell
the difference between ehrlichia and
Heartland virus will end up missing
cases we also need to be flexible one
size most certainly does not fit all for
tick-borne disease testing and you know
to put a finer point on it New England
doesn't need the same assay as Missouri
we have very different ticks at least
for the time being very different
diseases and it should drive how we test
and then finally we need to be adaptable
we need to have the ability to add
testing for new pathogens such as
heartland or Bourbon virus so just to
summarize here the commonality of
different tick borne diseases is
dramatically different across the United
States
common kick borne diseases in south
central United States includes
ehrlichiosis schooler emia and several
non-infectious diseases ehrlichiosis can
lead to life-threatening complications
this includes hlh necessitating a rapid
diagnostic for Licio and anaplasma
laboratory developed testing performed
on the Daiya sorne liaison mdx at least
in our laboratory is accurate precise
and sensitive testing using the liaison
allows for multiplexing for other
tick-borne diseases currently testing
for Babesia is also offered finally the
ability to multiplex create custom
panels and add testing for new pathogens
are in my mind essential essential
features of tick-borne disease
Diagnostics so with that I'll thank you
for listening to me today and I'd like
to take any questions from the audience
Thank You Neil for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
will answer as many questions as we have
time for our first question is tics are
nature's perfect vehicle for
transmitting microbes
did you encounter or detect any
co-infection through your validation
yeah that's a great question and you
know there is a lot of literature around
co-infections and it's certainly
something that everyone needs to keep in
mind with tick-borne disease hearing or
validation we did not actually see any
co-infections which I actually find that
quite interesting I will say though that
during our validation we were testing
for or Licio and anaplasma and those are
carried by two different ticks so it's I
guess from that from that degree it's
not too surprising that we didn't see
co-infections
but you know I do wonder in the back of
my mind if maybe we have any bourbon
virus or Heartland virus in there that
we don't know because we didn't test for
thank you do you think these
co-infections
are more likely to occur if the
causative agent of Lyme disease is also
present
so you know as far as it all it all
depends on what you test for so if as
far as Lyme disease goes that that the
tick that carries Lyme disease also
carries anaplasma which is easily tested
for through molecular techniques and
Babesia which is also easily tested for
so I think you're seeing a lot of
co-infections or a lot of code
detections with those organisms because
those are three that we were pretty good
at testing for as far as you know code
detection zorco infections with
ehrlichia the the challenge there is
there may be Co infections with things
like Heartland and bourbon it's just
we're not routinely testing for them so
so yeah I do think you're more likely to
see it with Lyme disease but I think
it's more of an artifact of what we
actually test for
thank you do you see a specific
population being tested within your
region for example men versus women
children versus adults um yeah that's an
interesting question I will say our
testing is driven by exposure so
patients that are out and about in the
woods our physicians don't necessarily
rely on the history of tick bite so you
know we're seeing a lot of young adults
being tested we're seeing a lot of kids
however we're also seeing a lot of our
immunosuppressed patients and
particularly we're seeing a lot of
patients that look look like they have
HLH there there we're doing a lot of
testing in those populations and like I
said it's kind of a wide age range but
we are pretty good about testing
immunosuppressed patients
immunosuppressed and really really sick
patients that we don't have a another
diagnosis for
great thank you according to literature
testing for tick borne infections
increased fivefold in the last 10 years
and the number of positive test results
increased threefold approximately are
you observing similar trend for
pathogens endemic to your region
um that's a fantastic question and
interestingly no what we're seeing with
our Licio rates anyways is they remain
pretty they've remained pretty constant
for the past four to five years we're
not seeing much of a change there I can
say what we have seen more of is when
we've test is we've started testing more
for some of the some of the other
viruses like bourbon virus and Heartland
virus and we're not seeing a ton of it
but we're seeing one or two cases here
and there you know like maybe once a
year so so we're just starting to see
those and those are kind of emerging but
as far as or Licio goes we haven't
really seen an increase and I think it
probably has to do with the fact that
yeah we're very aware of her Licio in
our area we know it's a problem and
we've been testing for it for a long
time and testing pretty often for it so
yeah maybe that explains why our Licio
rates haven't really gone up
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question
but BC on micro D is the most common
transfusion transmitted pathogen in the
u.s. do you think that implementation of
universal blood screening for abuse yet
is the way to go in order to prevent
transfusion transmitted abuse iosys that
you know that's a really great question
and it's a complicated question because
when we talk about testing the blood
supply we're talking about a very very
different situation and we're actually
using different tests to so we're using
serology and molecular testing now my
general take on this is is kind of
similar to PCR based testing alone one
size doesn't fit all
I think it makes sense to routinely
screen for Babesia in certain areas of
the country where Babesia is very common
in those areas you're going to have a
good positive predictive value and
you're going to very likely catch a lot
of potential transmission events however
screening it screening for it in areas
where Babesia is very uncommon very
unlikely could potentially cause more
harm than good because you know it's
particularly if you're using serology
you may have a very poor positive
predictive value and you may be
mistakenly kicking people out of the
blood donor pool who would have
otherwise it's based on false positives
who would have otherwise been able to
donate so I you know short answer I
think it's appropriate but I think it
needs to be done in a targeted manner
Thank You Neil do you have any final
comments for our audience
um no you know I think in general this
is a rapidly developing area and I think
it you know that the test that we see on
the market today I think are going to be
very very different in even one two
three years from now and you know what
what looks like a pathogen today or what
we are concerned about today you know as
far as some of these new viruses go we
may not care about years from now or
they may be the next big thing so
personally I think this is a very
exciting area and I myself am very
interested to see what happens in in
this field in the future
thank you again yell for your time today
in your important research we would also
like to thank labyrinth and our sponsors
via story molecular for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by two speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration lab roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye